This mockup is pretty similar to the portfolio mockup you worked on
in the previous lesson.
There are some differences, however.
For example, the layout of the work examples and
the color scheme, particularly that of the background.
You can see the colors and the hex codes on the left hand side of the screen.
But you should always start with looking at the design, and,
as always, consider the structure.
It should be pretty similar for
this mockup because it's so similar to the one you already did.
Despite the fact that you don't know anything about Bootstrap yet,
you can get started with a new webpage.
Now that you've got the design mockup, which steps can you complete now?
Can you create a folder structure for the project?
Can you create a DOM tree for the page?
Can you write HTML that defines the DOM?
Can you assign class names to HTML elements?
Can you write CSS?
And can you the test the page?
Check all that apply.